so let's review the idea of slope which
you might remember from your algebra
classes the slope is just the rate of
change of a line or the rate of change
of Y with respect to X as we go along a
line and you could also view it as a as
a measure of the inclination of a line
so the more inclined the line is the
more positive of a slope it would have
so this right over here this has a
positive slope it's increasing as x
increases and if this had an even higher
inclination like this if it increased
even more as x increases then it would
even have a higher slope so this right
over here is some line so that's some
line and just as a reminder we can
figure out the slope between two points
two points define a line and between
those two points we can find the rate of
change of of Y with respect to X so
let's put two points on here so let's
say that this point right over here this
this x value is X sub well this is
pronounced X naught or you just X sub 0
is just X naught and when and when X is
x naught for this line y is y naught y
naught so this is the point X naught
comma y naught and let's say we have
another point all the way over here and
let's say that this x value this x value
right over here is X sub 1 and the Y
value over here is y sub 1 so there's a
point X sub 1 Y sub 1 so just as a
review the slope of this line and a line
by definition has a constant slope
between any two points that you pick the
slope of this line which is often
denoted by the letter M is your change
of rate of change of Y with respect to X
or another way of thinking about it for
a given change in X for a given change
in X how much are you changing Y or
change in Y divided by change in X just
as a reminder this triangle that's the
Greek letter Delta it's shorthand for
change in whatever so change in Y over
change in X so let's think about what
this is going to be for this example
right over here well let's think about
change in X first so we are moving from
X naught to X
one so our change in X so this is our
change in X right over here we're
starting at X naught and going to X 1
that is our change in X I'll put that in
that pink color that is our change in X
and what is it equal to well if we're
ending here we started here let's just
let's just do ending point minus
starting point so it is X 1 minus X
minus X naught and that way doing it
this way I would have made sure that I
have a positive value I'm just assuming
that X 1 is larger than X naught now
what is my change in Y well once again
ending point ending Y value minus
starting Y value y 1 y 1 minus y 0 now
you might be saying hey could I have
done Y is y sub y naught minus y 1 over
X naught minus X 1 absolutely you could
have done that then you would have just
gotten the negative of each of these
values on the numerator the denominator
but they would have cancelled out the
important thing is that you're
consistent if you're subtracting your
starting value from your ending value in
the numerator you have to subtract your
starting value from your ending value in
the denominator as well so this right
here you probably remember from tape
from from algebra class the definition
of slope is the rate of change of our of
Y with respect to X or it's the rate of
change of our vertical axis I should say
with respect to our horizontal axis or a
change in Y or change in our vertical
axis or change in a horizontal axis now
I'm going to introduce a little bit of a
conundrum so let me draw another axis
right over here scroll over a little bit
just we have some space to work with so
that was for a line and a line by
definition has a constant slope if you
calculate this between any two points
it's going to be cut any two points on
the line it's going to be constant for
that line but what happens when we start
dealing with curves when we start
dealing with non line or non linear
curves so let's imagine a curve that
looks that looks something like this
that looks something like this so what
is what is the rate of change of Y with
respect to X of this curve well let's
look at at different points and we can
at least try to approximate what it
might be at any moment so let's say
that this is one point on a curve let's
call that x1 and then this is y1 and
let's say that this is another point on
a curve right over here x2 and let's
call this let's call this y2 so this is
the point x1 y1 this is point x2 y2 so
we don't have the tools yet and this is
what's exciting about calculus we will
soon have the tools to figure out what
is the rate of change of Y with respect
to X at exactly this point but we don't
have that tool yet but using just the
tools from algebra we can at least start
to think about what is the average rate
of change over the interval from X 1 to
X 2 well what's the average rate of
change well that's just how much did my
Y change how much did my Y change so
that's my change in Y for this change in
X for this change in X and so we would
calculate it the same way y2 minus y1
over x2 minus x1 so our change in Y over
this interval is equal to y2 minus y1
and our change in X our change in X is
going to be equal to x2 minus x1 x2
minus x1 so just like that we were able
to figure out the rate of change between
these two points or another way of
thinking about it is this is the average
rate of change for the curve between x
equals x1 and X is equal to x2 this is
the average rate of change of Y with
respect to x over this interval but what
if we have also figured out here well we
figured out the slope of the line that
connects these two points so we figured
out the slope of the line the slope of
the line that connects that connects
these two points and what do we call a
line that intersects a curve in exactly
two places well we figured out we call
that a secant line so this right over
here is a secant line so the big idea
here is we're extending the idea of
slope we said okay we already knew how
to find the slope of a line a curve we
don't have the tools yet but calculus is
about to give it to us but let's just
use our algebraic tools
we can at least figure out the average
rate of change of a curve or of a
function over an interval that is the
same exact thing as the slope of a
secant line now just as a little bit of
foreshadowing where is this all going
how will we eventually get the tools so
that we can figure out the instantaneous
rate of change not just the average well
just imagine what happens is if this
point right over here got closer and
closer to this point then the secant
line is going to better and better and
better approximate the instantaneous
rate of change right over here or you
could even think of it as the slope of
the tangent line